foreign
[Music]
was coming the leaves were swirling
that's the only way we knew it looked
like it was standing still
someone said run to the back me and
these two ladies here
we ran to the back we huddled together
and we pray for our lives
it's devastating it was uh say if you
was in the airplane and had to take a
higher altitude in your ears seems like
they're about to blow that's what it
felt like it was a lot of pressure it
was quick though it was it was less than
15 20 seconds
[Music]
was definitely the scariest moment of my
life so far I have a one-year-old son so
I was just thinking about him and coming
home to him and my fiance that was
really the only thing on my mind was
making sure that I made it out of there
okay and hopefully I could record a
little bit of it and just be able to
share with people that tornadoes do come
really fast and they create a lot of
damage really fast
holy
[Music]
it's right there
there was a show going on that night and
upwards of over 200 people present in
the building when the collapse occurred
Arkansas and the state government stand
ready to offer whatever assistance is
needed we've offered that to the mayor
here as well as other cities across the
state I also spoke with the FEMA
director chriswell earlier this evening
and have already requested federal
assistance and they are working quickly
to make sure that any resources that we
need on the ground here will be provided
foreign
[Music]